So that's how your immune system suppresses cancer.
The problem is, is that there's some issues.
And if we had a healthy immune system,
then nobody could cancer, right?
But that's not the case.
There's other issues going on.
So there's a phenomenon called Immutal Editing.
It describes how cancer cells can modulate
and kind of change their DNA actually
from a quantum physics standpoint.
They're changing their frequency.
And work as a survival mechanism.
They're just trying to survive.
Much like Lyme disease.
It's just doing everything it can to survive.
So just like another speaker said,
we'll let it survive.
Just nod in my body, okay?
We just don't want it in our body.
Same thing with cancer.
It's just trying to survive.
In an immune compromised individual,
this becomes even a worst case scenario.
It goes down this pathway even much faster.
Oh, goodness.
So there's three phases of immune editing.
First of all, your immune system is trying to eliminate the cancer.
Second phase, is it comes into balance with the cancer
and just keeps it at bay.
And this is where you hear that prostate cancer
could take 20 years to form.
Right?
That person had cancer for 20 years before now.
It became full-blown, quote-unquote, full-blown cancer.
It's because it can stay in that equilibrium phase
for a long time.
Your immune system is kind of playing this tug of war constantly
with it and keeping it at bay.
But it's not destroyed it.
So the first one is it is destroyed.
It's eliminated, which is the example that I gave you earlier,
where we all have cancer living inside of us
and what keeps me from getting cancer is my immune system.
Well, your immune system can also get it kind of an agreement with it.
You don't grow and you just stay there
and we'll leave you alone.
And that's the second immune editing phase.
The third one is that it escapes.
Meaning that it not like runs away escapes.
But it escapes and it realizes that the immune system
is not going to be able to kill me.
And it starts reproducing.
And that's where we have issues.
And that's where we have problems.
Because the cancer actually starts creating some molecules within itself
that keeps the immune system at bay.
So it almost like it learns how to survive in that environment.
So it starts creating molecules to reduce the ability of the immune system to kill it.
And that's where cancer gets more difficult.
So it can actually change its environment.
It creates immunosuppressive molecules.
It actually creates molecules that keep the immune system from destroying it.
So it gets really super technical
and I'm not going to get into too much of those things.
Question.
Is there a big difference between the cancer and what that is not Lyme associated?
No. There isn't.
No. But if a patient comes to me and they have cancer and it's caused by Lyme disease,
the priority is to treat the cancer.
So that's always priority in my book.
Cancer also secretes chemicals called Vegef.
Vegef is vascular and ethereal growth factor.
It's a chemical that causes an increased growth factor of blood vessels into the cancer.
So it's supplied with oxygen so it can grow faster.
Now this gets a little side note when we talk about nutrition.
So we very commonly have cancer patients come to us that have already done a lot of their homework.
And they're doing green drinks and they're juicing and they're doing all these really great things.
And that's real great.
That's beneficial for me because there's less education involved.
But just a little side note here.
A lot of people are into drinking juicing kale and spinach.
Really good vegetables for you, right?
Why are they really good vegetables for you?
So kale, even like about eight times more than spinach, kale produces nitric oxide.
So that is really good for you if you're dealing with heart disease.
So they may hear juicing kale.
Maybe I don't have to get into this discussion.
But doing green drinks, especially these things that are high in kale,
should not be done with cancer patients.
They'll increase Vegef production and they'll increase vascularization,
which you want to do with heart disease.
See this is again.
There's no standard protocol for all diseases either.
So heart disease has to be treated completely different than somebody with cancer.
So if a person comes to me and they have heart disease and cancer,
like is this your signal that I'm talking to?
That's me.
Then we have to treat it differently.
Follow me.
So just a side note, no kale drinks with cancer.
You'll increase Vegef production.
Kale's much higher than other ones.
Yes.